catch bucky brooks tonight on path to
the draft at 6:00 Eastern Time an NFL
mock draft live at 8:00 p.m. Eastern
Time Bucky thanks for calling it again
how are you brother you got it so we've
got mock drafts now that are close to as
reality as possible one would think a
week out from the draft yours is uh is
well researched and well discussed
amongst all of your colleagues in the
talent evaluation business you have Josh
Allen going number one overall why do
you think the Browns would take Alan
overed Arnold at number one I think you
check the history of John Dorsey I think
would make sense John Dorsey was that
Green Bay when I was dealing with Brett
Favre was a three-time MVP he saw that
and gunslinger good exceptional talent
and athleticism can do magical things
you take that and you then follow his
career as the leader of the Kansas City
Chiefs team over Eric Fisher over Luke
Joko a guy who was a better athlete so
y'all didn't take the projection over
the production he then a year ago
elected to go with Pat mahomes over
deshaun Watson and when you look at the
Shaun Watson he was maybe the more
polished player but Pat mahomes are so
tantalizing with his on talent his
gun-slinging
capabilities and his ability to make
things happen
off the cuff that you very well could
see John Dorsey fall in love with Josh
Allen see what Josh Allen could be if
you work out some of his issues because
he is athletic he does have a plus on
talent and he's big and physical he is
all those things that typically entices
Don Dorothy I could very well imagine
him being a Cleveland Brown so then that
would present the Giants with a unique
situation that they have Darnell drop
into their laps and then have an option
for say qualm Barkley have an option
obviously for Quintin Nelson if they
want to go offensive line although
that's a bit of a long shot now and then
there's Bradley Chubb a pass rusher or
the fact that I imagine anybody who
loves darn 'old like the Broncos who
have taken a look at him and the Bills
have taking a look at him I'm bringing
up Dave gentlemen to say that that offer
that we've been giving you for weeks it
now stands as real why do you and your
mock draft choose Brad
Chubb as the Giants option number two
overall once again it comes down to
studying the general manager you have to
understand David gentlemen was reared on
the knee of George Young and George
Young longtime objective for the Giants
believes that when you're the Giants you
have to excel at getting big people you
need to overwhelm people with your size
your strengthen your toughness and so
they've always believed in New York get
us a big man's game that the NFL is big
boy football and so those close to Dave
government have told me that he loves
the big guys and so when you look at
this board the two big guys that would
be intriguing plenty Nelson and Bradley
Chuck when you think about the immediate
impact obviously their team that could
benefit from a pass rusher you let jpp
go down to Tampa Bay so now you're
looking forward guys that can be a
dominant force off the edge Bradley
Chuck is that guy and the last time that
the Giants picked high up there when
they picked two overall they got a guy
named Lawrence Taylor hmm they always
have a tendency to harken back to the
past
Bradley Cho could certainly fit the bill
and being a dominant pass rusher but
I'll put a three by that because they're
gonna be some people in the building
that want to make sure that they elevate
the play of the quarterback Eli Manning
Dave gentlemen is a huge Eli Manning fan
he believes he's a standard for what a
franchise quarterback should be even
though he's declined a little bit they
believe they can put the right pieces
around him to get him back up to snuff
I'll say Quan boy he is a special player
a guy that can do it as a runner but
also as a receiver and the prospect of
putting an offensive line up their
features Odell Beckham jr. Sterling's
jeopardy Wow
Evan Engram and say Kwan Park in the
backfield is something that's going to
be enticing particularly to our
offensive coach like past Shermer they
could go that route because they want to
get the quarterback to play at a high
level and it wouldn't surprise me I'm
saying sure but I think fake on Park is
also a very very real possibility so
let's just stay with your mock draft
here 4.0 for those scoring at home Bucky
books mock draft is fourth the crack at
it here chatting with on the Rich Eisen
show then the Jets I mean this would be
I guess their dream scenario that darn
'old would drop in their lap at 3:00 but
Barclay
hee hee Barkley said he wanted he grew
up wanting to be a jet I'm wondering if
there would be any enticement at all
despite all of the draft capital they
used to move up to three that they'd go
Berkeley overed Arnold in this position
Bucky I mean even even though everyone
will say this fake Lombardi rates as the
best player in the draft there's a
fascination with quarterbacks and
quarterbacks are overvalued overhyped
and people are going to do whatever they
can to get a quarterback the New York
Jets haven't had a legitimate
quarterback takes naps and Chad
Pennington and so it's time for them to
get a quarterback so they can build
their team around the strength of the
quarterback and so if you're sitting at
3:00 and Sam Donnell is there I think
despite your love and affinity for sake
or Berkeley you have to take Donald I
think he would be the pick in that
scenario if he's there versus Barclay I
think they go at the quarterback not
only because the quarterback is an
immediate need but I think he has the
right personality to really be the guy
that can be the face of a franchise in
New York who call the kid tough um has
all the traits that you want to see in
terms of his intangibles and just know
he's only played a position four and a
half five years the best football for
Sam Donald is still ahead of him so you
know
darnell goes to the Jets and then you
got Barkley going to the Browns at four
which is again their dream scenario they
get that quarterback they want it one
and then Barkley still sitting there at
four you have Rosen over Mayfield by the
Broncos at five let's get into this rose
and stuff Bucky what what what are still
turning what is still turning people off
about Josh Rosen that he hasn't been
able to eye-to-eye man-to-man overcome
in these interviews I've I met him he
was here on this show just three weeks
ago he couldn't have been more
impressive and I I've got a BS meter
that that's that's as sharp as anybody
else is I didn't sense that from him at
all rich in the end people are scared of
what they don't know arm they're scared
and because the kid comes from a level
of affluence a level of exposure that
most people haven't been exposed to
they're scared on what he could be they
haven't taken the time to really get to
know him and to appreciate how that
diversity that worldly perspective can
actually play to his benefit um in a way
I see him very very much like Aaron
Rodgers a guy who needs to be stimulated
and challenged but a guy who's also
going to have interest at that extend
beyond football and for me as a parent
debt doesn't bother me but for some
football people that are really
old-school and traditional and they're
thinking they'll worry about does he
love it enough does he love the game
enough is he going to be committed to
the game or is he going to be fascinated
by what else is out there I'll say this
coming from where he came from to play
football in this time and era when
there's so many factors where people are
trying to get kids not to play with
parents that are well educated he has to
love it to continue to be in this game
so I don't have any worries about that
easy guy that can have like a
challenging personality to coach yeah
because I've coached him I've coached a
metal leaving the elite 11 advanced for
Trent Dilfer I know but he was on my
team however if you're not explain the
why if you don't have any insecurities
and your coach insell Josh Rosen won't
be a issue the issue to me or more with
the football people not with Josh Rosen
the kid is a really good player and when
we look back in five or six years I
think he's gonna be the best quarterback
in the dress yeah I'm into that I'm with
you a couple more minutes here with
Bucky Brooks and you know obviously I'm
using your mock draft to hit check the
boxes here the quarterbacks that are
gonna pretty much rule the first round
of this draft you have Baker Mayfield
falling all the way down 11 to Miami and
then the bills at 12 staying put
choosing Mason Rudolph in front of Lamar
Jackson why do you think that Bucky I
think Baker Mayfield
well Baker Mayfield is a really good
player he's an outstanding college
player but in most instances if you're
looking at Baker Mitchell as a talent
bacon maple doesn't have the kind of
talent that typically goes in the top
ten Baker Mayfield is undersized by all
quarterbacks standards he doesn't have
exceptional athletic
like a wealthy wilson and we can debate
whether his arm talent is really that of
drew brees in most instances a guy like
that is not drafted in the first round
drew brees went at the top of the second
round so just think about that so that's
why it's kind of hard for me to put they
can make doing that rarefied air when it
comes to mason rudolph / Lamar Jackson
I'm just looking for real it's the same
conversation that people are going to
have with Josh Rosen most NFL people are
traditionalists they like to deal with
things that are very very comfortable
that they've seen before they don't have
the ability to really tap into the
creative side Lamar Jackson is a guy
that requires a creative offensive mind
to understand what he is and what he
could do in the league we thought Bill
O'Brien revamped his entire offense to
allow deshaun Watson be the special
player that he was at Clemson and we saw
how that was rewarded defensive coaches
typically have a greater appreciation
for a dual threat quarterback because
they may love the challenges that come
along with defending a guy that can play
off the script Lamar Jackson is the most
explosive athlete that we've seen at the
quarterback position in some time he can
run it he ran twice for over 1,500 yards
in the ACC while also throwing for 3500
plus yard this is a tremendously
talented player however because he
doesn't fit the traditional box a lot of
people going bypass him and say that he
can't get it done because he doesn't do
it in a way that we seen some
traditionalists do it I think whoever
gets him is going to be very very
satisfied with him if they build that
often yeah I've seen stupid stuff like
hey you don't trust him on third and
long I mean it's that that's dumb
and-and-and-and-and
obviously not looking at the facts stats
game film and all that stuff with Lamar
Jackson and I think he's the special
written all over him too and you have
him landing in Baltimore what would that
mean for Flaco I mean what am I talking
about on draft night Lamar Jackson goes
to Baltimore with Mayock and the crew
about Flacco Bucky delivered to the
level of a 20 million plus quarterback
he hasn't playing very well they haven't
won a lot of games since their Super
Bowl they're really like let's be honest
you got hot going to playoffs he was 11
and 1 touchdown interception
and they did a good job but whenever the
flavors have really won it in the past
was always we're ready right scaring the
load and him playing as a sidekick
man we've seen what the franchise looks
like when he is the guy that has to
carry it and he can't carry um if you
start to connect the dots a week ago
they sign rg3 rg3 as a backup
quarterback for years we've always heard
you can't have a dual threat quarterback
because if he gets hurt you have to
change your offense for the second guy
well Baltimore is already setting the
table for if the mark Jackson comes in
as the starter rg3 is at the backup you
never have to change your offense I do
believe this reel and when you look at
the coaches that they have there Marty
Moore and wig because not only brett
farr but he coach Donovan McNabb and
Michael Vick and Philly he also has
experience dealing with Steve Young Greg
Roman who was the senior options of
assistant was in San Francisco when
Colin Kaepernick is there if you look up
and try and line up to dust the
Baltimore Ravens are more ready and
capable of dealing with a dual threat
quarterback Mark Jackson any other team
in the league I think it could be a very
real possibility that Lamar Coast fault
fantastic Bucky last one for your Daniel
again who's gonna be on tomorrow show
tweeted out yesterday in the middle of
the afternoon some crazy trade rumors
floating around today you retweeted that
saying crazy rumors if it happens it's
gonna make draft Nick's head spins it's
bananas with the emoji of a banana
hashtag QB chasing now all of luck I'm
an NFL media group guy too and I
understand that there's some
journalistic standards that are applied
to you and other draft Nixa you will not
hear on this show right now we're we're
removing that what what what are you
talking about what are you and DJ
talking about put meat in those bones
please what do you got okay we can we
can put meeting bones without naming
teams but I can say that in the NBA the
NBA typically deals with multiple team
trades to allow gas to acquire the kind
of assets and talents that they need to
move the kind of deal that we're talking
about is a seismic deal that will allow
all those teams or the primary teams
that we've associated with chasing
quarterbacks to be in a position to get
the quarterback that they want and there
will be a complete reshuffling of the
top five that's about as close as I can
get without reserve
but what we're saying is we could be
looking at a major cards shuffling deal
that allows the people to get the
quarterback so they want and put
themselves in a position to be satisfied
with the franchise quarterback to take
home for the next few years Wow
okay that's some breadcrumbs all right
Bucky love it we'll check on your your
latest move the sticks podcast with
Trent Dilfer who's on the show here on
Thursday and with DJ who's on the show
Wednesday I appreciate you being on this
Tuesday show you gotta that's Bucky
Brooks that Bucky Brooks on Twitter so
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience